[MUSIC]
I'd like you to do two things.
Firstly, think about the two most loved
ones in your life right now.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Great next I'd like you to rank them on a
scale of one to ten.
[LAUGH] This scale is how much you share
yourself with them.
Your inner most thoughts and emotions, one
being you share nothing,
ten being that you are a complete open
book.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Cool, seems like we all have it.
So, hold that until the end of this little
keynote and we will come back to that.
My keynote today is about relationships
and connections,
and about what holds us back from them.
See to me, a real relationship is one
where you share yourself with your loved
ones, you share your inner most thoughts,
you share your emotions in aid and
service of a better relationship but I
don't think we do that enough.
I don't think we have the strongest
relationships we could,
and the silent enemy here is our own
misperceptions.
What are misperceptions?
Well, if I'm trying to share myself, I
might be worried about protecting someone
protecting them from what my innermost
thoughts and emotions are.
I might be worried about changing the the
image I have and ahead of me.
Or worst of all, breaking a relationship
cuz we're scared of sharing ourselves.
And I notice, cuz I do this every single
day.
And it's something I'm trying not to do.
See, I over weigh the risks.
I worry about protecting people.
I worry about losing them.
And as such I don't share the risk I could
have share the [UNKNOWN] risks.
And even so, cuz I don't do it enough I
underweigh the benefits and
I don't do it again and
I don't want you to make the same mistake
with your close loved ones.
I'm gonna tell you a few stories where I
have closed myself off because of my own
misperceptions.
And hopefully you can open up then, from
there.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
I lost my father when I was six years old.
He went missing on a business trip and we
never heard from him again.
And my family went into chaos.
There was sadness.
There was anger and some depression as
well.
And from ages six to 13 I was told
nothing.
It took til when I was 13, and I was
totally oblivious before that point.
And I'm playing in the park with my uncle,
and his two, and his two,
and his sons, my cousins.
And I hear one of my cousins shout Dad,
Dad, pass the ball, and
something just dropped and I asked myself
a question.
He has a dad, where is my dad?
And misperceptions started filling my
head.
Was it my fault my dad had disappeared?
What were they not telling me?
What was the great secret?
I'd been a happy kid, before hand, I would
run straight home from school and
I would go to my family and tell them how
my day was, this changed.
I ran straight to my room every single day
for the next year.
I closed myself off from my family.
I dove myself into my books.
And I got great grades which they loved me
for
but I got validation from my grades and
not who I truly was inside.
And it took six months of counseling to
get past this,
six moths of counseling to get over the
grief, but
moreover realize that I was holding
misperceptions in my own head.
My family had lost a husband, an uncle,
and a son.
How could they tell a six or thirteen year
old boy,
your father isnt coming back, cuz that
would mean accepting it for themselves.
I realize this is a misperception, i was
wrong so
i became a happier kid from that.
I opened up to my family, i used to run to
them and
tell them how my day was, cuz I know it
was my own misperception.
But my misperception had closed me off for
a year and
a half to my family, I had lost that time
with them.
Now the next story is a teenage right of
passage it's one we
all know all too well I mean, it's telling
your parents you've been on a date.
[LAUGH].
It's that kind of story [LAUGH] shock all
around the room yep.
To give you some back story, my mother had
been on four dates with my father,
and they decided to get married very
traditional, in Indian society.
So, what I thought for my mother what she
wanted from
me was you go to a good high school,
[LAUGH] get great university,
get good internship, get great graduate
job,.
You can see where this is going [LAUGH] go
to great graduate
program Stanford MBA will do.
[LAUGH] Find wife and have a very good
life.
[LAUGH] Tick box.
[LAUGH] So I'm 18 I'm back home from
college.
It's the first time I'm back and I've been
on a date with this wonderful girl and,
for a week or so I'd been debating, do I
tell my mother?
A week later, I'm in the kitchen cooking
with her and
I finally decide to break the news to her,
but I'm worried.
What's she going to think of me?
Is she going to think less of me?
Will she think I'm not traditional, but I
say it anyway.
Cooking mushrooms and I say, Mom so I've
kind of met a girl.
Oh, you met a girl?
[LAUGH].
What do you mean met a girl.
Uh-oh.
We've been on a few dates.
Oh, Have you kissed yet?
[LAUGH] And at this point my heart is
going [SOUND].
My misperceptions are filling my head.
I'm just thinking oh God what do I do now?
But I decide to tell her, I say yes.
[INAUDIBLE] [LAUGH] And her reaction is
one that I never could have imagined.
Ooh.
[LAUGH]
[APPLAUSE].
>> Tell me more.
[LAUGH].
At this moment I realize my misconceptions
were all gone.
She didn't want me to follow traditional
path.
She was happy and excited for me.
And now I'm very open with my, about my
relationships.
If anything she's too involved now.
[LAUGH].
But that's a story for another day.
My final story is about getting to know my
father better.
Now as you recall, my father went missing
when I was six and
I have four memories of him.
That's four memories of someone who's 50%
of my DNA.
That's crazy, and last year, when I was
doing a talk at the GSP, I realized this.
But the reason I hadn't asked my family
since I was six, was because of the fact
that I thought they need to be protected,
it was a misperception.
Yes they were hurting, they had gone
through to strife.
If I open this can of worms up, then I
would be causing a family struggle, so
I had held back, but I realized I just had
to know, for
memories was not enough for me.
So I took my uncle into the cold sitting
room two Christmases ago.
We normally have a very jovial
relationship so he knew something was up.
He goes, Jay, this seems really serious.
What's going on?
And now my misperceptions are playing.
Am I going to hurt him?
Am I going to cause family struggles?
And these emotions start bubbling up
within me, and before I know, I'm saying,
I go, what the hell, I know absolutely
nothing at all, what the hell's going on,
I know four memories, you haven't told me
anything, I know you're hurting,
let me know his face, his jaw is dropping,
his face is getting whiter and whiter.
And my misperceptions are playing.
Oh, God, what the hell have I just done?
But his response, again, wipe my
misperceptions.
I can't believe we haven't talked about
this sooner.
I had no idea why you've never asked me.
And I know that we needed to have this
discussion.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Misperceptions, white my uncle didn't need
to be protected.
This wasn't gonna cause some family
struggle or strife.
But I, my own misperceptions had held back
knowing about my father since I was six.
I could have known, 19 years ago, about my
father, yet my own misperceptions that
held me back from finding out about 50% of
my DNA that's crazy.
And I don't want you to make the same
mistake that I did.
So I'll ask you this, go back to those two
people at the start of this little keynote
that you had in your head your two loved
ones.
And this weekend ask yourself
what misperceptions are you holding about
those two loved ones, that are holding you
from fully sharing yourself and having a
strong and great relationship with them?
And then just go, eh.
[LAUGH].
Take that risk,
cuz if those two loved ones aren't worth a
risk, then who is?
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]